yes they have former Cosby Show star
Jeffrey Owens who says it wasn't meant
to be I couldn't imagine myself in a
show like that because I'm such a
terrible dancer but hate the actor who
is shamed for working at a grocery store
is simply too busy now ETS confirmed
Jeffrey just bagged a guest starring
role on NCIS New Orleans he'll play star
Scott Bakula Szold friend who gives the
special agent advice Owens previously
accepted Tyler Perry's offer to shoot 10
episodes of his own show the haves and
the have-nots he also had Nicki Minaj
promised to give him $25,000 I hope he
doesn't take it the wrong way but I just
want to help him in any way I can but
after that offer is Nicki now getting
her own windfall you knew that when that
footage came out he was about to look
dumb since her headline-making fashion
week brawl with cardi B Nicki's podcast
queen radio has shot to number one on
Apple music the fight itself left Minaj
embarrassed I was mortified I could not
believe how humiliated it all felt
[Music]
[Applause]